what's in here what's it do and can I
make it from scratch it's the stuff
inside your stuff ingredients first
things first these are not shaving cream
they're actually shaving foam shaving
cream is more like face cream and that
deserves its own episode as does shave
gel and shave soap but today is all
about this guy and the truth is many of
you could probably shave your face with
just water you would though have to soak
your beard hair for a good two minutes
because that's how long it takes for the
hair to get hydrated and soft about 30
percent softer than normal but all of
these make the shaving experience nicer
and easier shaving products lubricate
the interface between skin and the sharp
blade and some people say they help keep
beard hairs wet during the shave so why
use one of these over another honestly
it's just personal preference the cream
and the gels tend to be a bit thicker so
if you have a thick beard that might be
for you whereas the foams and the soaps
tend to wash off a little bit easier
foam in particular is convenient I mean
it comes out of the can already lathered
up so you just stick it on your wet face
and you're off shaving now the two best
selling shave foams in the US have
basically the same ingredients they are
this one has BHT which is preservative
this one does not they both have
fragrances and it's actually kind of
amazing how different the fragrances are
this one is somewhat like a like a
locker room with wood cleaner and this
one sort of uh zigga like a citrus
citrus leather type smell shockingly
different hmm anyway aside from water
the essential ingredients can be split
up into five types the first is a
lubricating soap in this case tri
ethanol amine stearate now te a stearate
which you can think of as stearic acids
chemical cousin is responsible for
making all that lather which reduces
friction between the razor blades and
you face the second category are the
foam boosters or laureth 23 and sodium
lauryl sulfate which help make all that
lather extra creamy the third category
is the fragrance and the fourth is the
preservative in this case BH
an antioxidant that helps prevent the
can from corroding now the last group of
ingredients are the propellants
specifically isobutane and propane which
are both flammable and explosive so
whatever you do do not just kidding at
reasonable temperature and pressure this
will not combust because there's not
nearly enough isobutane and propane to
make this whole thing flammable in fact
I could take a lighter to it and as you
can see it does not combust but you
should still not try this at home
because this can is under pressure now
you might be wondering why there are
propellants in shaving foam well it's
what makes the foam a foam now foams in
general are formed when pockets of gas
get trapped in a solid or a liquid
inside our can here we have the first
four ingredients I showed you there are
also the propellants which are gases at
room temperature and pressure so you'd
expect that they'd sit above the liquid
since they're less dense but the whole
can is pressurized at 2 to 4 times
atmospheric pressure which ends up
liquefying some of the propellant
meaning it actually dissolves in the
soapy mixture below when you press this
button the propellant gas at the top
expands pushing the liquid down which in
turn pushes it up through the straw out
the nozzle and into the world now here
is the absolutely insane part remember
that the soapy mixture coming out of the
nozzle that has some liquefied
propellant dissolved in it and when that
liquefied propellant hits our atmosphere
it turns back into a gas which gets
trapped in the surrounding liquid
creating bubbles billions of them now
those bubbles are way smaller than
anything you'd get if you just lather up
with soap or use one of these air pump
and foamy things and it's the tiny Ness
that gives shaving foam its structure
now that we know what's in shaving foam
and how it works I'm gonna try and make
my own from scratch using only natural
ingredients I'm going to start with the
exact same ingredient you find in
commercial shave foam with stearic acid
which I'm going to react with sodium
hydroxide and that will get us stearate
which hopefully will produce a rich
creamy lubricating lather both of these
by the way you can get from nature and
sodium hydroxide can be a bit dangerous
which is why
wearing safety gear I'll also use this
natural soap as a foam booster because
it foams up real nice for fragrance
rosemary essential oil and because I
don't want to be dealing with pure
concentrated flammable gases I'm going
to use nitrous oxide as my propellant
and I'm going to use this whipping cream
canister to dispense my phone so let's
get started
you
[Applause]
you
you
this is getting slimy
which is a good sign for a lubricating
soap
you
[Music]
some tight now we charge it
let's give it a shake all right moment
of truth huh hey that's not bad
it did foam up I can see the bubbles and
it's not quite as structured as the
commercial phones I would guess that my
stearate concentration is probably too
low for that but let's now see how this
actually performs on my face I didn't
soak my beard hair so this is probably
gonna hurt but for science yeah by the
way this smells amazing this is really
not bad at all this shaving foam is
performing whoo smooth Hey
very well I am I'm impressed I would
give this an 8 out of 10 now if you guys
have ideas on how to improve this recipe
let me know in the comments if you have
an idea for an episode hit me up on
Twitter and in the meantime I'm going to
finish shave me
you